Speaker 1: Let's go next to. Oh, how about
Magnus from Norway? Magnus, you're on the air.
Can you hear me? Just barely, Magnus, I'm going to
pump you up, pump up your volume as much as I can.
Speaker 7: Um, well, let me try first. Wow.
Speaker 1: You're barely audible.
Speaker 7: Yeah, wait a second here.
Uh. Why is it so low? OK. Is it
possible to try again? A little bit later?
Speaker 1: Yeah. You know, if you speak up,
I've pumped you up 200 percent, so maybe
we can hear you if you have a question.
Speaker 7: Erm, yeah, I was just
wondering, um, what do you think about
privatization of electricity?
Speaker 1: Privatization of
electricity. So are you talking about
the generation or the distribution?
Speaker 7: Um, I guess you can say both.
Speaker 1: Hmm. I have no reason to think
it's something we should do. Why would
we why would we want to do it, I guess.
Speaker 7: I know like the reason I'm I don't
know if I'm pro or anything but like, um.
I feel like it will help in reducing the
price of electricity in homes and stuff
like, for instance, in Norway. We have had
some increase in the cost of electricity.
Yeah, because uh, as my mother says, she says
that it's because of the EU that we have to
increase the prices of like water, for instance.
Um, but I'm like, if if we just privatize it,
wouldn't it like decrease the prices?
Speaker 1: It's not obvious to me that it would,
you know, I can only speak to the United States.
But in the United States, electricity is quite
regulated in different states have different
configurations, but one argument would be open
competition and then it will reduce the price. But
the other side of it would be actually it would
actually increase the price once you make it a for
profit model. Now, in some states where there's
been deregulation, you can change your electricity
supplier, you can shop around. But the complexity
with electricity is the delivery. The delivery is
still happening by one company because otherwise
you need if you want to change power company,
you need different power lines, and that's very
complicated to have each company run its own
power lines. So if you concede that the delivery
needs to be based on one infrastructure, you
then start to kind of have a little bit of a
question mark around what gain, what benefit there
really is to opening it up in the way that you're
suggesting. So I'm just not sure about that.
Speaker 7: Oh, thanks for answering it.
Speaker 1: My pleasure, Magnus from
Norway, thank you so much for the call.